Oh in the hell do you think you are
I was awesome
nice suit
good what's that he says welcome to the
frickin gaudy into the galaxy
holy you didn't use fricken
oh look out oh wow I tried guys
the fate of the universe lies in your
shoulder now whatever you do don't push
this but Nelson bomb immediately and
we'll all be dead now repeat back what I
just said Congress no that's the button
it won't kill everyone try again
colder mm-hmm Oh uh-huh Donna may hold
[Music]
does anybody have any tape out there I
would have put some paper over the debt
but nobody has anything not a single
person has take you have an atomic bomb
in your bag if anybody's gonna take you
that's a really bad sign
give me touch someone and see how
they're feeling
yeah yeah yeah I guess yeah I feel a
general unselfish love first but I don't
know I don't know ha ha ha ha Oh
everyone your deepest darkest secret
dude gone you're overreacting a little
you must be so inside ha ha ha ha ha
donation
you